BREAK.
IN I'M TRACE GALLAGHER.
NOW BACK TO HANNITY.
HANNITY.
WE HAVE MORE REACTION TO
THIS BLOCKBUSTER NEWS ABOUT
JAMES COMEY AND A MAY 2ND
EVEN COMPLETE.
LET ME JUST STAY ON WHAT HE
IS EXONERATING HERE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
MISHANDLING OF CLASSIFIED
TOP SECRET, SPECIAL ACCESS
PROGRAMMING:  MOM AND POP
SHOP BATHROOM.
WE KNOW THAT SHE LIED WHEN
SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T HAVE
THIS INFORMATION ON THERE.
THAT SHE DIDN'T SEND A
RECEIPT.
THAT'S BEEN DEBUNKED.
THEN YOU HAVE THE WHOLE
THING ABOUT DELETING 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
THEN YOU HAVE THE ACID WASH
AND THE USE OF BLEACH BIT,
MOST AMERICANS HAD NEVER
HEARD OF IT BEFORE.
THEN YOU HAVE AN AIDE
BUSTING UP DEVICES,
THING THEY TURN OVER TO THE
FBI IN TERMS OF A DEVICE IS
ONE WITHOUT A SIM CARD,
RENDERING IT USELESS FOR THE
FBI.
NOW, THAT SOUNDS TO ME.
IT IS OBVIOUS THAT LAWS WERE
BROKEN HERE.
AND THAT WE NOW KNOW FIVE
FOREIGN AGENCIES TAPPED INTO
THAT PARTICULAR SERVER, THAT
COMPROMISED NATIONAL
SECURITY.
DOES THAT MEAN NOW THE FIX
IS IN WITH COMEY AND
STRUREB?
WE HAVE TO DO IT ALL OVER
AGAIN?
>> I THINK A COUPLE THINGS
HERE THERE IS A REPORT OUT
TODAY THAT SHE APPARENTLY
HAD A DEAL.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE EXACT
LANGUAGE.
A DEAL WITH THE OBAMA
WANTED TO, WHICH APPARENTLY
INCLUDED AN ENTIRE SECTION
ON HER OUTREACH TO THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
FIRST OF ALL, THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO VIOLATE LAW
BY HAVING THIS KIND OF A
DEAL.
SECOND, THIS IS A WHOLE NEW
ZONE THAT JUST SHOWED UP
DURING THE DAY TODAY AS A
REPORT OF A SPECIAL
ARRANGEMENT THAT SHE HAD
MADE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ALL
THIS STUFF AWAY, EVEN THOUGH
IT WAS ILLEGAL IN TERMS OF
THE SECURITY.
>> Sean: WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
>> YES, WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
LET ME DRAW THIS INTO TWO
PARTS FOR A SECOND, SEAN.
PART ONE IS HILLARY AND THE
ENTIRE GANG FROM THE
FOUNDATION THROUGH HER
AIDES, ET CETERA, THAT'S GOT
DEPARTMENT.
THE CONGRESS HAS TO INSIST
AND, FRANKLY, ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS HAS TO
INSIST THAT OF THESE ARE
GOING TO BE PURSUED NOT AS A
MATTER OF VENGEANCE.
NOT TO GO AFTER PEOPLE, BUT
BECAUSE THE RULE OF LAW, THE
VERY BASE OF THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM REQUIRES THAT WE TAKE
SERIOUSLY WHEN POWERFUL
PEOPLE ARE CORRUPTED.
AND YOU HAVE BOTH A CLINTON
SEPARATE CASES.
THEY BOTH HAVE TO BE BROUGHT
TO LIGHT AND PEOPLE HAVE TO
BE PROSECUTED.
SESSIONS RECUSED HIMSELF
>> WAIT, WAIT.
HE HAS NOT RECUSED HIMSELF
ON ANY OF THIS HE RYE COULD
YOU SAID HIMSELF NARROWLY ON
NOT RECUSED ON WHETHER OR
NOT THE FBI WAS CORRUPTED.
AND HE IS NOT RECUSE COULD
YOU SEED ON WHETHER OR NOT
THE CLINTON TEAM WAS
CORRUPTED.
HE HAS AN ABSOLUTE
OBLIGATION.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU.
DIDN'T RECUSE HIMSELF ON
URANIUM ONE AND THE DOSSIER.
THAT CAME UP, TOO.
BECAUSE I HAVE KNOWN JEFF
SESSIONS A LONG TIME.
AND I WILL JUST SAY FLATLY.
IT'S TIME FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE AND DO HIS JOB.
HE HAS NO EXCUSE AS SOMEBODY
WHO I KNOW BELIEVES IN THE
LAW.
HE HAS NO EXCUSE FOR HIDING
HE HAS TO SET UP A CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS TO SET UP AN FBI
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS HIS OBLIGATION UNDER
THE LAW TO ENFORCE IT AND TO
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
INVOLVED.
THEM HEAD ON.
OR HE IS FRANKLY NOT DOING
HIS JOB.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK I
COULD SAY IT ANY BETTER.
IT'S SERIOUS.
WE WILL STAY ON IT.
INTERESTING.
ISN'T IT SAD, PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST NEWS STORY IN OUR
LIFETIME POLITICALLY AND THE
NEWS MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY
HAS BASICALLY IGNORED IT AND
HAS -- THEY HAVE BEEN
CO-OPTED BY A PHONY
NARRATIVE.
AND THAT THEY SPREADING LIES
AND FAKE NEWS FOR A YEAR.
AND BEING CAUGHT REGULARLY
AT IT.
LAST WORD.
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE END OF
THEIR WORLD.
IF THE CLINTONS GO DOWN AS
HARD AS I THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO.
AND IF THE CORRUPTION OF THE
FBI GOES DOWN AS HARD AS I
THINK IT'S GOING TO.
THEN THE ELITE MEDIA WILL
HAVE BEEN MORE SEVERELY
DAMAGED THAN ANY TIME IN THE